- This tastes like I'm gonna be peeing
in a parking lot, in public later tonight.
- This tastes like pee in a parking lot.
(whipping noise)
(jazzy drumming)
- We're taking vodka that's
supposed to taste better
because it's gone through a filter,
but one of them is gonna taste like shit.
- One of these is filtered
once through, and one of
them's filtered twice.
- Yes, and then one is unfiltered.
- I'm really a whiskey person, so I'm
not looking forward to any of this.
- Same.
- I'm expecting severe PTSD back to like
my freshman year.
- How much filtering can, like,
get rid of bad memories?
- [Both together] Bam, bam, bam.
- [Man] Oh my god.
- [Woman] Cheers.
- Okay.
- I actually didn't hate that.
Well, no, then it burns.
- Ohhh.
- I could've shot that entire thing,
and not, actually, I'm
gonna shoot the whole thing.
- I've had shitty cheap
vodka, and it's not,
it's worse than that, I
think that was filtered once.
- Uhhh, please don't be bad.
- Ugh, agh!
Agh!
- Ugh.
- Yeah, that wasn't good.
- I think that was worse.
- You know that feeling when you get
soda and then you burp and
it goes into your nose?
- Oh, that was so much worse than that.
- This piece of shit
wasn't filtered at all.
- [Man] Last
- [Woman] All right, ready.
- But not least.
- Oh.
That's not as bad as
this one, this one was--
- (inhaling sharply)
- That one wasn't bad.
- Quick Russian lesson, vodka translates
to sweet water, and this is what this
was the most like.
- This will get you friends
if you bring this to a party.
100%.
- The second one is unfiltered,
and one of these is filtered twice.
- The first one was
definitely the worst one,
so that was filtered none.
- [Both together]
Filtered a bunch of times.
Filtered zero times.
Filtered once.
- This one was filtered once.
This one's unfiltered.
And this one was filtered twice.
- [Man] Oh, wow.
- [Woman] Oh, yeah.
- Okay.
- It works.
- This is like a good college hack.
I shouldn't say that, but like,
we all fucking drank, let's just be real.
- Give me bourbon--
- Yeah.
- Any day of the week.
- You need to filter whiskey.
Think about it.
- Be careful with this.
I know it seems like the cheapest option
and you know you're in that liquor store
and it's $10, but just be careful, okay?
At least put it through the filter.
(jazzy music)